laurence belet bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl or depuis la sphère
duhamel les témoignages d'abus sexuels
sur mineurs se multiplient comment est
ce que vous pourriez expliqué que ce qui
relevait du secret du tabou de l'omerta
il ya quelques années puissent enfin
s'exprimer les écouter bon c'est vrai
que la parole à il ya une parole qui se
libère sans les verts beaucoup d'autres
ça c'est un phénomène qui est connu je
pense que parce qu'il ya une grosse une
grosse crainte de ne pas être crue par
les victimes
en plus de la difficulté en plus de
l'amnésie traumatique en plus de tout ça
donc le fait de se sentir pas tout seul
je pense que c'est très encourageant et
ils disent que finalement peut-être
qu'ils vont être pris au sérieux
et quand en plus vous n'êtes pas pris au
sérieux c'est insupportable quoi ça veut
dire quoi que c'est à dire que quand les
victimes elles franchissent un
commissariat par exemple en face d'elles
elles n'ont pas toujours les enquêteurs
à un accueil finalement une écoute de la
part des enquêteurs
ah bah il ya beaucoup y en a la peur de
gala elle est d'être déjà c'est qu'on la
croit pas effectivement c'est alors les
enquêteurs des garanties et ja contacter
francis et aria et qu'elles ont reçues
est long de la séance
fois on va commencer par là parce que
c'est pas beaucoup de victimes qui
arrivent eux jusque là après alors les
enquêteurs faire leur travail mais de
toute façon en général ça va être après
des murs de dénier déjà les personnes
qu'ils accourent et de quasiment tout le
temps elles reconnaissent pas là la
preuve est très difficile à établir
et c'est un véritable parcours du
combattant c'est très très dur
moi je suis que je prenais beaucoup de
victimes qui ont porté plainte une fois
et qui disent que elle recommencerait là
vous commencez pas en fait ont été
victimes de plusieurs agresseurs parce
que c'est souvent le cas mais moi j'ai
trop souffert pendant processus
judiciaire j'ai du mal à voir ce que
j'ai du mal à envisager de reporter
plein y en a aussi qui m'ont dit
si j'aurais pas porté plainte comment
encourager justement ces victimes à
s'exprimer aujourd'hui par quel biais on
voit que ça certaines d'entre elles
choisissent de s'exprimer par le biais
des réseaux sociaux est ce que ça à mon
premier pas pour vous écouter c'est
peut-être la solution c'est pas du moins
pire
c'est vrai que c'est mieux et bien sûr
c'est mieux d'aller en justice ou de
saisir le parquet on va vous payer mais
le problème c'est que il faudrait que
c'est sûr derrière donc finalement c'est
un peu le dernier recours c'est
équipements de réseaux sociaux et ne
s'était que ça fait avancer les choses
voyez donc et c'est quand il ya eu des
balances ton for me to on a dit on on a
dit aux femmes pour aller porter plainte
dans les commissariats ex voilà il ya eu
35 plaintes en plus dans le mois qui a
suivi mais il n'y a pas eu 3 % et en
plus y'a pas une moyens en plus donc
enfin de moi j'ai commencé à recevoir
des coups de fil de jean king et dcc que
de porter plainte ce qui arrive pas j'ai
passé des heures et des heures dans un
commissariat les policiers sont débordés
n'était pas davantage vous dire ils sont
débordés parce qu'on leur donne pas de
moyens
voilà gala de toute façon l'institution
judiciaire suit pas et la fiche les
enfants comme l on cite encore plus on
va commencer là on se heurte à un
problème de moyens donc finalement les
réseaux sociaux ça permet au moins une
libération de la parole et le fait qu'on
commence un petit peu à prendre
conscience du problème qui est majeur
est un enjeu de santé est très important
parce que effectivement
est-ce que vous il vous semble que les
autorités publiques n'ont pas pris
suffisamment en considération les dégâts
provoqués sur ses victimes et dégâts des
abus convoqué sur ses victimes à bas à
l'aune des moyens qui sont dits oui
visiblement non ont déjà et tu as l'air
que d'ailleurs 16 mois quant à elle est
reconnue victime
après bienvenue ces normes très mal
après pro tellement elle se débrouille
elle va avoir des dommages et intérêts
qui en général
un peu importants et puis et puis s elle
a les moyens de se soigner tant mieux
pour elle puisqu'elle a pas les moyens
tant pis y'a y avait une mort après
c'était déjà ça n'a pas changé une vue
la mère d'une victime qui disait lui
donc elle parlait de l parler du type
qui avait violé sa fille qui a été
condamnée d'ailleurs il est lui il est
arrivé alors en prison il a été nourri
l'a vu un médecin
on va donner un avocat et à 10 et et moi
avec ma gamine je me débrouille et c'est
exactement ça elle s'était retrouvée
parce que parce que effectivement si on
imagine que ça ça répare pas tout une
réparation financière aujourd'hui c'est
indispensable
elles doivent être revues à la hausse
selon vous ces réparations financières
bien sûr que la hausse
et je dis bon alors après c'est vrai et
puis peut-être qu'elles sont basses
aussi parce que quand le quand les
agresseurs peuvent pas payer c'est
l'état qui paye c'est le fonds de
garantie des victimes d'infractions
pénales donc met de côté pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée les les horizons
prend les enfants de victimes d'outreau
pour avoir été violée torturée enfin
détruit donc toute leur enfance
l'affreuse qu'ils ont subi vous voyez
ils ont à lui l'angle était donc on sait
entre 15 et 30 mille euros chacun le
mieux indemniser des enfants à tous et
30000 euros le mwh vienne en isère où
ses 15000 euros l'est alors que les les
a quittés mais acquittés d'outreau ont
leur donner un chèque de 1000 euros
à la sortie de du procès en assises du
procès d'appel
il y en a qui ont touché plus de vous
voyez donc en fait les indemnisations
des danses des enfants de victimes des
victimes est très vaste
ça c'est vrai c'est vrai pour tout en
les et les victimes de général
d'accidents corporels pour ça on est pas
du tout les états unis une campagne choc
a été lancée 1
il y a quelques jours en france
justement pour dissuader les adultes de
commettre des crimes pédocriminels
comment est-ce que vous la jugez cette
campagne est ce que vous la comprenez et
si je comprends pas votre question vous
avez vous avez une campagne qui a débuté
il ya quelques semaines et sur cette
campagne on peut lire des phrases disons
aux adultes de consulter si jamais ils
ont des pulsions pédocriminels comment
est-ce que vous la jugez cette campagne
écouter tout ce qu'ils annoncent ans je
veux bien tout ce qui peut tout ce
qu'ils essayent de protéger les enfants
ça va dans le bon sens à mon avis ça
sert pas à grand chose
vous voyez et et cette histoire se dire
c'est celle de soigner de soigner les
prédateurs voilà je dérange tourne en
fait on essaye encore d'aider les
adultes et c'est un petit peu toujours
comme ça et je suis patient et très
dubitatif quant à son efficacité
l'histoire du soin de dire y avait déjà
la loi guigou qu'il était préoccupé de
soigner les prédateurs avant alors qu'on
soigne toujours pas les ensembles et il
ya quand même génial et récidive ont pas
bougé vous voyez mes donc leur folle et
faut les traquer comme le font certaines
associations comme on l'a vu dans le
reportage
je ne sais pas mais en tout les
problèmes à la source
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus hélas parce
que effectivement il peut y avoir des
prédateurs ont été dans leur enfance
ouais pas tout ça y'a énormément aux
équipes une par prédateurs pour autant
mais voilà mais j'ai l'impression que
vous avez lé in health est un trip neil
qui fait comme les autres
eminem essayer ça parce que ça lui fait
pas parce qu'il en a envie et ils
essayent de pâques sergio p donc après
peut-être on peut considérer que la
criminelle est une maladie mais mais le
côté fait pas ça à les consulter
j'avais envie honnêtement j'y crois j'y
crois très peu donc après des citoyens
qui est des collectifs de citoyens
s'emparent du problème
à partir du moment où la justice est si
inespéré mais si peu de moins qu'en mai
lorsque le le moyen qu'ont mais pour
protéger les enfants
face au fléau qu'est la pédocriminalité
wiba de ma foi pourquoi pas c'est
toujours pareil à la société civile
elle commence c'est comme le reste du
car ça elle commence à prendre les
choses en main quand l'état est
défaillant
merci beaucoup l'auront ce bonheur
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin dans la
matinale de arte je le rappelle vous
êtes journaliste auteur des droits de
femmes et des enfants
l'intolérable indifférence aux éditions
michalon